اعلنت شرطه الباكستانيه مقتل شرطي واصابه
خمسه اخرين بينهم مدنيان وذلك بعد ان فجرا
انتحاري سياره ملاغمه كان يقودها بالقرب
من منطقه سكنيه بالعاصمه اسلام اباد وقالت
الشرطه في بيان الانفجار وقع عند حاجز
امني اقامته الشرطه ضمن سلسله اجراءات
الاحترازيه بعد تلقيها معلومات استقباريه
تفيد بوجود تهديد امنيه
من اسلام اباد ولي المتابعه ينضم الي من
جديد مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر
مرحبا عبد الرحمن حدثتنا في الساعه
السابقه عن الخلفيه المحتمله الان هل
تكشفت معلومات اكثر عن ملابسات هذا الحدث
الذي مثل ما ذكرت لم تشهده منذ مده
العاصمه الباكستانيه
نعم بالفعل محمد من عند السنوات حقيقه لم
يقع اي نوع من انواع اعمال ال الارهاب ان
صح التعبير هنا في العاصمه تحديدا بالرغم
من ارتفاع ملحوظ في عدد الاعمال الارهابيه
في مناطق القبائل او المناطق المحاذيه
للحدود مع افغانستان على وجه التحديد
وتحديدا خلال الاسابيع السته الماضيه
الجديد حقيقه الذي تكتشفه ومعلومات غير
مؤكده حتى الان من مصادر مطلعه في جهاز
الشرطه وتحديدا في جهاز البحث الجنائي
التابعه للشرطه الحديث عن ان نحو 15
كيلوغرام من المواد المتفجره كانت في
السياره التي كان يقودها ذلك الشخص الذي
اضطر لتفجير نفسه بعد ان حاول الفرار من
حاجز الشرطه وقامت الشرطه بملاحقته
بالمناسبه بهذه السياره التي تشاهدونها
حاليا في خلفيه الصوره هذه السياره التي
استعملها رجال الشرطه لمحاوله اللحاق
بالشخص الذي كان خذ تركي السياره والتي
اشتبهت الشرطه فيها وتمكنت من ملاحقتها
لكنه اثناء الملاحقه قام بتفجير نفسه داخل
السياره ما تحول هو والسياره الى اشلاء
وبالفعل هناك بعض الاضرار حتى في المنازل
ال- ال- ال- المحيطه بهذه المنطقه بموقع
التفجير حتى الان التحقيقات ما تزال
مستمره محاولات رفع كل ما يمكن رفعه من
ادله همم تشير همم
تساهم ربما في همم محاوله التعرف على
الهدف الذي كان يسعى هذا المهاجم
لاستهدافه من خلال ترك السياره المليئه
بنحو 15 كلغ من المتفجرات محمد شكرا جزيلا
لك عبد الرحمن مطر مراسل الجزيره مدير
مكتبنا تحديدا في اسلام اباد